vamos a resolver algunos ejercicios de
cómo escribir expresiones básicas con
variables y vamos a empezar con esta que
tengo aquí que dice escribe una
expresión para siete por r entonces si
aquí escribo siete después tengo que
poner este símbolo este puntito que
significa x y ahora sí puedo poner r ojo
también puedo poner simplemente siete r
es exactamente lo mismo
7.3 que 7 r muy bien así que déjame
comprobar la respuesta
y vamos a ser el siguiente dice escribe
una expresión para 11 más que am bueno
tengo 11 pero no me voy a quedar
solamente con 11 a éste 11 le voy a
sumar a esto porque dice 11 más que a
ojo también puede haber empezado con a
ya a sumarle 11 más es exactamente lo
mismo tener 11 más a que a más 11 por lo
tanto ambas respuestas son correctas
vamos a revisar de lujo y vamos a hacer
el siguiente bien ahora quiero escribir
una expresión para 6 - acá y lo que
quiero hacer es escribirlo en términos
matemáticos por lo tanto voy a poner
aquí al 6 y al 6 le voy a quitar acá
pero en lugar de escribir menos m n o s
lo que voy a hacer es poner un símbolo
matemático que es este aquí este símbolo
representa el menos y entonces voy a
tener 6
a 6 le voy a quitar campo y vamos a
comprobar mi respuesta
de lujo vamos ser uno más en este caso
dice escribe una expresión para 8
dividido entre de entonces lo que tengo
que hacer es poner 8 y dividirlo entre
de 8 dividido entre de muy bien vamos
ser uno más
primero comprobemos la respuesta y vamos
al que sigue dice escribir una expresión
para 12 por equis bueno voy a tomarme al
12 y voy a multiplicarlo por la equis
justo como decía en el primer ejercicio
muy bien el que sigue y ahora voy a
hacer este que es muy parecido el
anterior tiene una expresión para 9 x t
bueno al 9 lo voy a multiplicar por t
es exactamente lo mismo poner 9 t vamos
a ver de lujo estamos bien así que hasta
el siguiente vídeo